hello he asking me on a date she didn't  seem that impressed  you clean up pretty good yourself don't  you look fine this evening we're on a  date very nice took you long enough to  ask  so why did you give up your life on  earth we boarded the Avalon with the  destination 120 years hibernation means  a wake-up in a new century on a new  planet  a year ago everything changed  do you know what's going on nobody else  is awake I think something went wrong  with the hibernation box  you both come too soon 90 years too soon  you should go back to sleep  something's wrong something big what do  we do  do you trust me  this ship is going to go  or something I have to tell me  there's a reason we woke up early  you